twitter can be a very interesting place
for discussions that touch on
things that matter and how we ought to
structure our life how we ought to
prioritize so we've got this great
conversation happening around this tweet
from steve
dot millionaire habits or steve on speed
who tweeted out there by age 30 you
should have a group of friends that talk
business money and fitness not politics
and pop culture and you notice there's
over 6 000 retweets over 10 000 quote
tweets 33 000 likes and this is quite
interesting because at least in my
twitter feed most of the people that i'm
seeing responding to this don't really
like it and
i think there's a great conversation to
be had around this some of which is
joking some of which is very serious so
let's jump right into it first off steve
followed up with a few things that i
think provide a bit of interesting
context so one of the things that he
said immediately after this was one of
the biggest mistakes i've ever made was
making friends with like-minded folks
who talked about the same [ __ ] over and
over i agreed with 99 of it your comfort
zone will kill your progress and there's
probably something to that i'm not sure
that it aligns all that well with his
command that we should have a group of
friends that talk business money fitness
and not politics and pop culture because
it you know you can be just as
hive-minded when it comes to business
money and fitness as you can with
anything else another thing that he said
that i think is kind of interesting and
lends a bit of context as well when i
was 30 i was overweight reckless and
alone today i'm in the best shape of my
life married to the love of my life and
100 financially secure life is good now
in some sense this would support what
he's saying right by age 30 you should
have everything figured out except for
the fact that he's saying he turned out
okay and when he was age 30 he
definitely didn't have everything
figured out so which is it should we go
the one way and narrowly circumscribe
our friend group to those who speak
about certain topics or should we
figure this out as we go on and you know
from age 30 on maybe we can readjust or
something like that
there's an initial problem that got
raised by this tweet by
saul sawler woe very original steve by
age 30 should also be writing your own
tweets and so you know they went in and
found some other accounts that were
talking about
these sorts of matters not exactly the
same thing but kind of similar so really
the advice that's being given here is is
kind of a of a genre rather than really
original advice moving on this
distinction between business money and
fitness on the one hand and pop culture
and politics on the other can be called
into question as we see these two tweets
doing business money and fitness are
politics and pop culture you can't
separate the concepts of business and
money from their political context and
pop culture determines most of what's
considered fit some good points i think
there and then another tweet here by age
30 you should stay away from accounts
talking business and money
without
politics
making a similar point and moving on we
find this great quip by kevin mchale
some of us have friends that can talk
about all five topics business money
fitness and politics and pop culture i
think that's a good point as well and
we're going to see some other
discussions of this friend group
starting off with a pop culture
reference from blockbuster plus
blockbuster plus has obtained exclusive
footage of steve and his interesting
friends and if you don't recognize that
those are stills from the movie american
psycho in which you know patrick bateman
and all of his buddies get together and
they're looking at business cards and
talking about all the different ways in
which they're trying to you know gain
money and power and prestige with each
other and it's kind of a stuffy
context you could say
there's another great quip here though i
was going to say by age 30 your friends
should just be patrick bateman but
at least he was into music and there's
that famous scene where he's talking
about huey lewis and the news so even
patrick bateman is into pop culture to
some degree isn't he moving on um here's
some other good observations and now
we're getting to things that are not
just poking fun but getting quite
critical by age 30 you should stop
taking advice from social media
especially twitter i think that's a good
point by age 30 you ought to be able to
recognize a soulless friendless grifter
at 100 paces and we're seeing this
grifter thing coming up here another one
person with bad advice spends money he
got from sheep taking his bad advice to
spread his bad advice even further and
then finally by age 30 you should
probably know that grifters will try to
get your money out of you by trying to
make you feel inadequate
in some way
don't fall for it and i leave it to you
to decide whether or not steve
millionaire habits is a grifter or not
it's certainly a debatable point
going on here we start getting into some
you know reflections about what really
matters in life and how we should
understand friendship great point made
here by janet potts friends aren't
transactional they're who i hang with to
de-stress and relax with i am not my job
my job is what i do to make a living and
if i need to network i'll find people to
discuss business with
you're conflating business contacts with
actual
friends i think this is a great
distinction a great point we see a
similar thing being said by subject
impermanence maybe just hang out with
people you like friendship shouldn't be
once again we see the word transactional
that's just sad and then a very funny
retort by jared oh yeah well then i'm
not going to offer you the once in a
lifetime opportunity of investing in my
pyramid scheme transactional and also
grifty as well pocket raptor vivian says
how about having a friend group that's
just as passionate about you
and your hobbies and interests and
actually wants to partake and said
hobbies or interests with you i think
having supportive friends is more
important than a bunch that's mainly
focused on materialism and that's a
really great point the notion of
friendship here is very truncated isn't
it kate willett writes by age 30 you
should have two cats one who is really
snuggly another one who is naughty and
destroys your stuff in a funny way and
you might say what's that that one doing
here well it's about priorities cats are
not unless you're breeding them for some
sort of you know weird show thing
they're not really an investment
opportunity and they're not going to
give you advice about business or
finance or anything like that let alone
help you get fit even if you do
something like cat yoga at the same time
cats do make good friends
we get deeper into the what really
matters and how to make sense of these
things in this set here and this is a
great one by martin tune when you're 42
and recently finishing cancer treatment
trust me conversations about business
and money become pretty useless
conversations about your friends loves
fears passions goals values what makes
them tick and shared experiences are way
more
useful and notice that he doesn't just
say valuable he actually says useful
there which is really what we're talking
about here's another good one from dame
senorita felicidade always hope i'm sure
you mean well but this tweet is fiercely
confirming my suspicion that chasing
after wealth is a pursuit that breeds
shallowness of character by 30 one
should hopefully have a group of friends
with whom we share mutual respect love
and unconditional acceptance saying
that's where the friendship priorities
should really lie and here's another one
from cipher 7 let's forget about steve
who seems to have set an arbitrary best
before date for life that's rubbish by
age 30 you might have found out what
brings you joy and what feeds your mind
and soul and learn not to listen to the
likes of steve who thinks with his
checkbook again you know identifying a
mistaken set of priorities here's
another one by age 30 from nick the
linux experience experiment by age 30
you will probably
know not to give a rodents bottom about
random advice from people who treat
their life as a career and that's the
really key thing they're treating one's
life as a career finally jeff tedrick
pro tip don't take advice on friendship
from people who use money as a metric
for
self-worth money is not the measure for
everything and sonya the bad country
follows up by your 40s or 50s or sooner
you realize that people who talk
frequently about their money or wealth
are nothing but insufferable shallow
bores call me dull but i prefer to talk
about amazing books podcast gardening
hobbies documentaries shows on netflix
etc so we have a host of other valuable
things besides just money business and
fitness being highlighted here going on
colin t is maniacal says by age 30 you
should have grown out of this high
school mentality and found a group of
friends that you trust and respect and
enjoy interacting with instead of
judging people on their small talk like
relationships or business transactions
you need to get the return on investment
on amigos good point there james corey
the science fiction author who we know
is actually several people working
together is being a millionaire worth
the price of all your friends being
boring twits
ryan malus says not everything is a job
my dude and a good point as well and
then finally thomas james hustle culture
perpetuates so much ugliness in the
world neither waste your breath on or
subject your friends to such mean and
boorish conversation is that about
business money cultivate a friend group
with whom you can have convivial
beautiful edifying conversations and you
know i think there's some good points
there i don't know that you necessarily
can't talk about money or business that
can be very interesting as well but that
shouldn't be it that shouldn't be
everything that's going on then we get
to some of the really great joking
responses that
reveal something in the jokes so megan
basham says by age 30 your friend group
should include one former tax collector
an insurrectionist and an impulsive
fisherman who's she referencing there if
you don't know
well that's uh jesus of nazareth right
so
he does have you know matthew the former
tax collector peter the impulsive
fisherman and simon the zealot dr ben
gazer talks about a important
philosopher by age 30 you should have
moved to a garden in athens and spend
your days discussing philosophy and eat
little pots of cheese who is he talking
about epicurus and then we get some
great fictional ones coming from sci-fi
by age 30 you should have passed the
kobayashi maru from star trek and made
the kessel run in less than 12 parsecs
from star wars right and we have another
one from star wars as well from death
star pr by age 30 you should have a
group of plucky rebels including one
princess a chosen one a pirate a wise
old hobo a space bear and two
merchandise friendly robots plotting to
take down a galactic empire and then
finally the famous speech from blade
runner given by rutger hauer by age 30
you should have seen attack ships on
fire off the shoulder of orion and watch
sea beams glitter in the dark near the
tan hauser gates isn't that wonderful we
also have some stuff from fantasy as
well by age 30 you should have a group
of friends willing to share the burden
of taking an ancient magic ring to be
destroyed in a volcano lord of the rings
right and then we have false by the age
of 30 you should be a well-established
adventurer who travels with a diverse
group of fellow adventurers working
quest after quest to help save the realm
from a once dead chaos god with the
occasional shopping episode and holiday
special of course and then finally a a
complete reference to dnd by the age of
30 you should have a group of friends
that consists of a tank a healer a melee
assassin an arranged spell caster
so these are quite great and then some
more pop culture references by age 30
you should have 106 miles to chicago
full tank of gas half a pack of
cigarettes and be wearing sunglasses
that of course is the blues brothers
after one of them picks the other one up
at joliet prison right and then finally
there's a reference to the steve miller
band by age 30 you should have nine
friends the space cowboy maurice a
picker the grinner a lover a sinner the
joker a smoker and most importantly the
midnight toker so these are you know a
lot of fun
now moving on a little bit about age and
putting things into perspective about
what we should be demanding or what we
should be advocating
zero reynolds says here's my advice for
by the time you're 20 and surprise
unsurprisingly it is the same advice for
by the same time you're 30 40 and beyond
ready by the time you are insert
milestone age here you should be
actively seeking your own happiness on
your own
terms that's it cheers
soul writes hello my friends as your
resident 30 year old let me tell you by
30 you should have 30 years of age and
experience under your belt that's it
everyone progresses in their own way and
at their own pace don't let make anyone
make you feel bad for having your own
journey in life and then christina
reinforces this by saying by age 30 you
should know that you were on your own
path and shouldn't be guilted to fit the
mold of somebody else know that the
person you are is the person who
survived all your good and your bad
times know that tweets going viral
doesn't mean that they are the truth so
some great wisdom there maybe we don't
actually have to have these sorts of
milestones here's another wonderful one
by scott lynch by age 30 you should have
two wolves inside you resting
contentedly having devoured the five
uptight trophy friends some weirdo on
twitter said you had to get and then
finally we have one more tweet and boom
you've been rick rolled by age 30 you
should have a group of friends that are
never gonna give you up never gonna let
you down never gonna run around or
desert you so there you have it a great
set of responses to this interesting
tweet that i'll point out too
is good for not just starting
conversation but if we look at it more
carefully is he actually saying that you
should only have this friend group that
you exclusively talk about these three
topics with and you definitely don't
talk about the other two topics with i
don't read it that way but i i
understand that nearly everybody else
did and i think it's great that people
have chimed in and we have this
wonderful conversation about good
priorities for a happy life
you